Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux !
Vous connaissez ce sandwich ?
Évidemment, puisque chaque année,
nous en consommons environ 350 millions.
Ça calme et ça cale aussi.
Alors certains l'appellent le kebab, d'autres le sandwich grec.
C'est ce qu'on va essayer
de trancher aujourd'hui dans l'atelier.
Et vite, avant que ça ne refroidisse.
Bienvenue dans Sur la planche.
Si ce format vous plaît, n'hésitez
pas à liker la vidéo et à vous abonner !
Je pourrai ainsi vous régaler
régulièrement.
Bon, alors je vous l'accorde, le kebab,
ce n'est pas ce qu'il y a de plus diététique.
Mais une fois de temps en temps,
ça ne fait pas de mal.
Alors, pour trancher sur ses origines,
grecques ou turques,
nous allons faire un peu d'histoire géographie.
Mmmh !! Le goût du savoir.
Apparemment, tout a commencé dans l'Empire ottoman. A la fin du Moyen Âge,
on y consommait déjà de la viande grillée, découpée au fur à mesure de la cuisson.
Ce ne sont pas des paroles
en l'air, on a des preuves.
Un chevalier français,
Bertrandon de la Broquière,
pas facile à porter, évoque ce mode de cuisson.
Il le raconte dans le récit
qu'il fait de son voyage
à Istanbul, aux alentours de 1430.
Je le cite. Attention,
c'est du vieux François. Me firent les Turcs,
mengier char rostie, ce soir,
qui n'estoit point cuitte à moittié à beaucop,
et la trenchions en rostissant en la broche.
Heureusement, vous aviez la traduction.
Au début,
on fait griller la viande à l'horizontale
au-dessus d'un feu de bois.
Mais progressivement, ce mode de cuisson passe de la campagne à la ville.
Or, en ville, les rues sont étroites.
Les broches horizontales
sont peut-être devenues trop encombrantes dans les petites échoppes
et les kebabiers auraient eu l'idée
de les mettre à la verticale.
Mais rien n'est certain.
Toujours est-il que quelques siècles
plus tard, la broche tient debout
dans toutes les rues de l'Empire ottoman et commence à faire parler d'elle.
En 1909, un guide touristique
attire l'attention des voyageurs sur,
je cite, ce mets très apprécié, composé
de viande de mouton rôtie à la broche que
l'on découpe en toutes petites tranches
au fur et à mesure qu'elle est bien cuite.
Mmmh !! Ça donne envie.
Du coup, les Grecs n'ont rien à voir
dans cette histoire.
Si, un peu quand même.
Nous étions en 1909.
Quelques années plus tard, en 1923,
le traité de Lausanne,
à la suite de la Première Guerre mondiale, redessine les frontières de la région.
Fini l'Empire ottoman.
Ben oui, il ne faut pas oublier
que l'Empire ottoman
était l'allié de l'Allemagne
et que l'Allemagne a été vaincue.
Il nous l'avait dit qu'il
y avait de l'histoire et de la géographie
dans ce sandwich.
Ça va, vous digérez ?
Ce traité fixe les frontières
de la nouvelle République de Turquie.
Il organise aussi
l'échange des populations.
Les Turcs de confession musulmane
vivant en Grèce doivent quitter le pays
et s'installer en Turquie,
alors que les Grecs chrétiens orthodoxes
vivant en Turquie doivent faire le trajet inverse.
Sauf que certains Grecs de Turquie
choisissent
une autre destination européenne,
Paris ou Marseille par exemple.
Ils y installent de petits commerces,
des restaurants où l'on mange,
devinez quoi ?
De la viande grillée sur une broche verticale.
Puisqu'ils sont tenus par des Grecs, ces restaurants sont appelés gyros,
ce qui en grec signifie tourner en référence à la broche.
Kebab signifiant viande grillée en arabe.
La confusion entre kebab
grec et gyros
vient de là.
Et pas des ingrédients
qu'on trouve dans le sandwich ?
Non, car à cette époque, le kebab ou sandwich
grec que l'on consomme aujourd'hui
n'existe pas encore.
Cette viande est découpée et servie dans une assiette.
Elle se mange à table, avec une fourchette et un couteau.
L'idée du sandwich est beaucoup plus récente.
Elle viendrait cette fois d'Allemagne, où
beaucoup de Turcs ont émigré durant la seconde moitié du XXᵉ siècle,
emportant avec eux leurs recettes, qu'ils ont fait évoluer.
Trois restaurateurs en revendiquent
la paternité.
Toujours est-il que ce n'est
que dans les années 1970
que la viande est glissée à l'intérieur
d'un petit pain.
Peut-être se sont-ils inspirés d'un
certain Iskender Efendi qui avait réalisé
cette présentation en 1867 dans la ville de Bursa, au sud d'Istanbul.
Et depuis les années 70, le grec ou
le kebab se mange à toutes les sauces.
Allez en cuisine !
En gros, un kebab c'est un sandwich
avec de la viande grillée sur une broche qui tourne à la verticale.
Mais à partir de là, toutes les variantes sont permises.
En France, par exemple, on consomme
traditionnellement des viandes en sauce.
Les kebabiers ont eu l'idée
d'y mettre de la sauce blanche
pour s'adapter au goût local.
Mais au Japon, il est présenté avec une sauce au curry.
En Allemagne,
on le consomme plutôt dans un sandwich garni de chou fermenté et au Mexique,
la viande est mise dans une galette
de maïs accompagnée de guacamole,
de la sauce à l'avocat. Même chose pour les viandes.
Il y en a pour tous les goûts : agneau, poulet, bœuf, veau.
Même pour le pain, il y a le choix.
Pain pita, baguette, tacos.
Eh salut Chef !
Alors pain ou tortilla ?
Personnellement, c'est le traditionnel que je préfère dans un pain pita.
Salade, tomates, oignons ?
Le classique, le complet.
Et la sauce, sauce magique beau gosse ?
Pour moi, c'est sauce blanche maison.
Et vous, quelle recette préférez vous ? Laissez la moi en commentaire !
Merci chef.
Ça a l'air bon.
En résumé,
la viande grillée à la verticale viendrait de Turquie.
Le sandwich grec ou kebab aurait été inventé
en Allemagne par un ou plusieurs immigrés turcs.
Quant à la sauce blanche qu'on y ajoute,
elle est typiquement française.
Vous vous y retrouvez ? Pour ne vexer personne, faites comme moi,
allez au kebab et commandez un grec
ou chez le grec pour commander un kebab.
Avant de vous quitter, il ne me reste plus qu'à vous remercier
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo. Efkaristo, ça c'est
en grec et pour ne vexer personne, Tesekkür Ederim,
ça, c'est en turc.
Pourquoi les chats n'aiment-ils pas l'eau ?
Pourquoi ronronnent-ils ?
Comment fonctionnent leurs yeux ?
Je réponds à toutes ces questions
et à bien d'autres
dans ce petit livre #DisJamy, publié chez Nathan.
Vous y trouverez également des expressions et un quiz autour des chats.
Le lien est ici.